The next topic I want to talk about is voting.
Voting involves lots of cryptographic issues
and there are many interesting security
properties that a voting system should
provide. One property that many voting
systems desire to provide is anonymity that
it shouldn’t be possible for an adversary to
know who someone voted for. The other
property a voting system should have is that
the count is verifiable. These are shorter
than opposition. Verifying the count would
be easy as each voter would be willing to
publicly declare their vote and someone
could look at all of those votes. But if you
want to keep the votes anonymous and
have a notion of private ballot, well then
verifying the count becomes more challenging.
Another property some voting systems want to provide
is coercion-resistance. What this really means is that a
voter can't prove who they voted for if votes are secret
and there is no way to prove for whom one votes, well
then, there is no way to coerce the voter into voting a
particular way.
And then we have all the usual goals of reliability
and security. These things are hard to achieve.
There are good ways to achieve them with
paper ballots if we have trusted ballot boxes
guarded by trusted election officials and if we
have enough trusted third-parties, well maybe
we can trust them to report the right tally.
We’re going to look at one interesting cryptographic
way to do voting, but I want to emphasize that this is
not a solution to the real problems that are
necessary to running election. But it solves this
issue of can you keep votes anonymous and still
have a way to verify that the count is correct.